- [Voiceover] So we have
this function, f of x,
expressed as a rational expression here,
or defined with a rational expression.
And we are told at each
of the following values
of x, select whether f has a zero,
a vertical asymptote, or
a removable discontinuity.
And before even looking at the choices,
what I am going to do,
because you're not going
to always going to have
these choices here.
Sometimes you might just have to identify
the vertical asymptotes, or the zeros,
or the removable discontinuities,
is I am going to factor this out.
And hopefully, or I'm going
to factor the numerator
and the denominator to hopefully
makes things a little bit more clear.
And we are to think
about what x values make
the numerator and, or the
denominator equal to zero.
So the numerator, can I factor that?
Well, let's see.
What two numbers, their
product is negative 24,
and they add to negative two.
See, that would be negative
six and positive four.
So we could write x minus
six times x plus four.
Did I do that right?
Negative six times four is negative 24.
Negative six x plus four
x is negative two x.
Yeah, that's right.
Alright, and now in the denominator,
let's see, six times four
is 24, six plus four is 10.
So we can say, six, x
plus six times x plus 4.
So let's look at the numerator first.
The numerator zero if x is equal to
positive six, or x is
equal to negative four.
The denominator is zero if x is equal
to negative six, or x is
equal to negative four.
So, let's think about it.
Can we simplify this, what
we have up here a little bit?
And I, in other words, keep in
mind what I just wrote down.
Well it might be, just
jumping at it, you get
an x plus four divided by an x plus four,
why can't we simplify this
expression a little bit?
And just write this whole thing, write
our original expression as being
x minus six over x plus
six, where x, if we want it
to be algebraically equivalent
we have to constrain
the domain, where x cannot
be equal to negative four.
Well this is interesting
because before, when x equals
negative four, we had all this
weird zero over zero stuff.
Well we were able to
remove it, and we were able
to make it this kind of,
this extra condition.
And if you were to graph
it, it would show up
as a little bit of a
removable discontinuity.
A little bit of a point discontinuity,
just one point, where the function
is not actually, is actually not defined.
So in this situation,
and this is typical where
there's a thing that you can factor out,
it was making the numerator
and the denominator
equal zero but you can factor that out,
so it no longer does it.
That's going to be
removable discontinuity.
So x equals negative four is
a removable discontinuity.
And once you've factored
out all the things
that would make it a
removable discontinuity,
then you can think about
what's going to be a zero
and what's going to be
a vertical asymptote.
If it makes, once you've
factored out everything
that's common to the
numerator and the denominator,
if of what's left, something
makes the numerator
equal to zero, well,
then it's going to make
this whole expression equal to zero
and so you're dealing with
a zero, so x equals six.
Six would make the
numerator equal to zero.
Six minus six is zero.
So there you're dealing with a zero.
And to make the denominator equal to zero,
you would get x equals negative six.
That would make the denominator equal zero
so that's a vertical asymptote.
It's called a vertical asymptote
because as you approach this value,
as approach negative
six, either from values
smaller than negative six
or larger than negative six,
the denominator is going to
become either very, very, very,
it's either going to become a
very, very, very, very small
positive number or a very, very,
very small negative number,
so we're going to approach
zero either from above or below
and so when you divide by
that, you're going to get
very large positive values or
very large negative values.
And so your graph does stuff like that.
So you have a vertical asymptote.
It might either do something like that
or it might do something like this,
where this is your vertical asymptote,
and then when you approach from here,
it goes, it bumps up like that.
So either way, so that's why
that's a vertical asymptote.
Let's do another one.
Alright, so same drill and like before,
let, we'll always pause the video
and see if you can work
it out on your own.
Let me factor it.
So let's see, two numbers,
product is negative 32.
They're going to have
different signs, eight, four.
And then we want the
large one to be positive
since they have to add
up to positive four x.
So x plus eight times x minus four.
Yep, I think that's right.
And then divided by, this
is four times four is 16.
Four, negative four plus
negative four is negative eight
so this x minus four times x minus four.
Now this is really, really interesting
because you might say,
oh, I have an x minus four
x minus four, maybe, x equals four
is a removable discontinuity.
And it would have been unless you had,
if you didn't have this over here,
because x equals four, even
after you've factored this.
You still can't, the
expression, the function,
is still not going to be
defined when x equals four.
And so this function is
actually equivalent to
x plus eight over x minus 4.
I don't have to put that
extra little constraint
like I did before.
I don't have to put, I don't have to put
this little constraint that describes
this removable discontinuity
because the constraint
is still there, after I've factored out,
after I've cancelled out this x minus four
with this x minus four.
And so here, we've, this is
actually an algebraically
equivalent expression to
this one right over here.
And so now, we can think about
what the zeros or the vertical asymptotes
or the removable
discontinuities are going to be.
Well, something that
makes the numerator zero
without doing it to the
denominator is going to be a zero.
And x equals negative
eight makes the numerator
equal to zero without
doing anything to, without
making the denominator equal to zero.
It would make the
denominator to negative 12.
So you could literally just
evaluate h of negative eight
is equal to zero over negative
12, which is equal to zero.
So that's why we call it a zero.
What about x equals four?
Well, x equals four is going
to make the denominator
only equal to zero, so that's going
to give us a vertical asymptote.
And we're all done.